wie oder was glaubt ihr max und herzlich
zu einer runde gestern zusammen mit
stores mit mir alles micro brennt schon
wieder weg irgendwas stimmt mit meinem
micro dass es schon wieder gebrannt hat
weiß auf jeden fall schon mal was
brennen ich musste nur zweimal dagegen
schlagen dann heißt der oft verbrennen
was ist das sind wir ja leute das ist
der weihnachtszeit ist folgendes
schreiben die leute auch immer so will
ich dachte du hast eine kerze da und
nicht mikrofon und deshalb gleich mir so
claire jetzt weihnachten dann
bekanntlich soll tatsächlich mal wieder
kehrt zum zins einfach mal an
ernsthaft ich glaube das wird ja und
wenn ich es nicht mache abonnieren oder
dafür abonniert mich dafür bitte wie
weihnachten
ich fahre weihnachten ganz cool zu
bekommen dass sie darüber rede ich darf
darüber reden
ich habe zwei schönen sohn aus boxen
bekommen kein zu tun hat ja hab ich auch
cool und davon habe ich zwei coups der
wahl schnell verdammt
du bist 105 400 520 und richtig
schlechter anfang apps leider finden wir
hätten nicht zwei super coole sau nach
boxen kommt machte sie stutzig so toll
oh ja danke und danke an nicht wirklich
wahrscheinlich wirklich
und dann habe ich meine mama noch so ein
tolles stars für ordnung dass sebastian
gewesen hatte sebastian starterset für
eigenen office mäßig weil ich halt echt
alles todes ungeordnet ab immer und ich
hatte mir gar nicht von meiner mama
gewünschten dann hat mir das geschenk
des vereins dies voll gut überlegt und
was habe ich natürlich nicht so viel wie
sonst mache ich habe ich hab mein herz
in köln bekommen ich nur ein neues handy
weil mein handy lange wieder den geist
aufgegeben hat nur neues handy das ist
so aber darf man heuer
ich habe überhaupt keinen kaum bekommen
ich habe ganz viele bekommen eigentlich
das iphone ding das access ist das
glaube ich und ist es dort ist hast du
das sechster schon alles was mir jemals
persönlich habe in meinem leben ist das
nicht ich mache ich jede zwei jahre und
ich habe jetzt das erste mal dass plus
genommen lacht tatsächlich also das
große und ich muss sagen bis dato bin
ich zufrieden damit
okay ist halt schon so batzen aber wenn
man halt wieder mit arbeitet dann ist
das schon echt ok und praktisch
arbeitest du denn so richtig auf dem
handy
ich bin halt viel unterwegs irgendwie
auch in herten und dann halt ein
bisschen größer screen vielleicht ein
bisschen schneller weil mehr reingepackt
ist aber wurde dom zu mainz eigentlich
schon so mobil ist netflix und stelle
dann aber zb auch dass ich glaube ich
weiß aber was das ist
das stört mich aber ich glaube es liegt
eine post- und ich an dem die dumme post
glaube ich so ein pulli geschickt um der
war voll cool noch nicht bei race
gesehen
deswegen denke ich dass dieses bild der
ist eine irgendwo gesehen eher was für
ein foto von youtube logo offen statt
also youtube habe ich nicht gesagt ihr
könnt alle mal auf sturm ich kanal gehen
und gute besten sturm ich schreiben und
ihn ab und sein neuestes video licon
über kuranyi war jetzt mal das video
jetzt wird aber nicht einfach wichtig
genommen wie schädlich likes kleine
videos und sogar 1500 1500 4000 lose
4001 kraft das video easy und 2 3 und 2
ich bin richtig schlecht 800 insider
das ist das los aber gleich komplette
gäste auf die keinen bock hab von meiner
mama ich deine videos gucken oder nicht
auch ich hatte das immer so scheiße also
ja ich kein bock auf die also wirklich
ich habe auf mein schwert 32 level
roboter 24 anbrechen weil 30 level
ja ich gebe auf schwert ist es ganz
krank und hab kein also leute das ist
ein scheiß witz dieses schwert es ist
das ist eine provokation
ich habe sieben 100 coins glaub ich werd
ausgegeben ist hat smart 4 am rechten
bein ob beck 23 nichts wiederholen nicht
positives warum er von den fluten
ok-chef 13 auch noch drauf also wirklich
wenn ich dir ohne irgendwas anderes
weise reise dann liegt das schlimmste
schwerter zeiten haben uns drei geräten
auch aber dafür dass sie 800 points rein
gebuttert habe man es mal probiert ganz
viele leben wir nur zu holen und gar
keine rüstung weil sie so mit dem ganzen
geld für sich habe okay nicht wollt ihr
ja es nämlich pinto
dazu ist heute mit wirklich lästig aber
diese vollkommen videos behindert ist
fertig der so viel leben hat ganz
schnell eine zweite rolle nicht so klug
glaube ich mama ich danke schön
ok ich hab' keine rüstung wieder auch
schon wieder klar die große frage lautet
was in dem teich ja dann weißt du dass
der typ der den aktiven typ ist walter
jonat auf bogen gesetzt richtig krank
ja das gibt es auch alter junge
ich bin gerade richtig gut an
du bist aber nicht denn apa also warum
brennen hoffe ich dass wissenschaft ich
hab sie geschäftsleute